>> David: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT IN AN IMPROMPTU INTERVIEW
WITH "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
PRESIDENT TRUMP PREDICTING THAT
IS NOT CALLING FOR AN END TO THE
INVESTIGATION HE SAID "THE
COUNTRY."
WE WILL GET BACK TO THAT IN A
EXCLUSIVELY OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS
FROM HOUSE INTELLIGENCE CHAIRMAN
DEVIN NUNES TO DEPUTY
WANTS TO KNOW BY THAT DATE
WHEN THE WITNESSES COMMITTEE
SUBPOENAED BACK IN AUGUST ABOUT
THE DOSSIER WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY.
HE ENDS BY WRITING, AND I QUOTE
AGAIN "AT THIS POINT IT SEEMS
THIS LETTER COMES ON THE HEELS
FROM THE WASHINGTON AND
EXAMINERS BYRON YORK THAT NUNES
IS ISSUING -- WITH TIES TO
SENATOR McCAIN.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FLORIDA A ATTORNEY GENERAL PAM
GREGG JARRETT, PAM, FIRST TO
YOU, LOOKING AT THIS AS SOMEBODY
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WITH A LOT OF HIGH-PROFILE CASES
WHEN YOU GET THESE QUESTIONS
INFORMATION PRACTICES TWEETS,
WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU ARE AT
THE TOP OF THIS?
>> WELL, HE IS DOING EXACTLY
WHAT HE SHOULD DO, AND I'M PROUD
OF WHAT HE DID.
I START OUT BY SAYING AS A
CAREER PROSECUTOR MY ENTIRE
CAREER AND A THIRD LARGEST STATE
OF COUNTRY, THERE ARE ABOUT
40,000 GREAT MEN AND WOMEN OF
AND THAT IS NOT FAIR TO THE
AND BY THE WAY, STRUCTURED NOT
BE IN HR, HE SHOULD BE FIRED.
WE HAVE JAMES BAKER ALLEGATIONS,
WE HAVE ALL OF THESE THINGS, SO
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THEY
HAVE TO TAKE IT UPON THEMSELVES.
GREGG WILL AGREE TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE RIGHT WAY
THE RIGHT WAY.
AND TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE IT.
THIS INVESTIGATION SHOULD BE
UNITED STATES.
>> David: YOU KNOW, GREGG,
WASHINGTON IS AN INTERESTED CITY
BECAUSE THERE IS A BUREAUCRATIC
DEEP STATE OUTSIDE OF PARTY HOW
THEY LINE UP THE SIDE.
BUT TO PAM'S POINT, THIS HAS
BECOME CLEARLY BIASED IN SOME
WAYS, AND THE STALLING, THE
COVER-UP, THE VARIAN FACTS AND
DATA, AND DEVIN NUNES, WHAT IS
HE SMILING HERE?
>> HE SMELLS A COVER-UP, THERE
IS ONLY ONE REASON WHY HE WOULD
DEFY AND STONEWALL AND EVADE A
LAWFUL CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA
FOR FOUR LONG MONTHS.
AND THAT IS IF YOU ARE TRYING TO
HIDE EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING ON
THE PART OF THE FBI AND THE
DOSSIER.
IF IT IS TRUE THAT IT WAS A
COMPLETE FABRICATION AND THE FBI
KNEW IT AND NEVERTHELESS THEY
USED IT TO LAUNCH THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION, THAT RENDERS THE
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION A CHARADE
AND D LEGITIMIZES MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAVE THIS ALL TOO COZY GROUP
OF GUYS, JAMES COMEY, ROBERT
MUELLER, WEINSTEIN, WISEMAN,
EXCUSE ME.
>> David: WIND WISEMAN, BRUCE
OHR.
>> THEY WORK TOGETHER FOR YEARS
AND YEAR, SOMETHING UNSEEMLY,
BECAUSE OF THE STABILITY ON THE
THE FBI, AND IT SEEMS TO BE
DETERMINED TO FIND WRONGDOING ON
THE PART OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHERE NONE EXISTS.
>> David: PAM, UNFORTUNATELY
YOU CANNOT SEPARATE THE LAW AND
NATION'S CAPITAL.
SO EVEN AS GREGG SAYS AND LAYS
OUT THE COMMAND AS YOU HAVE
TALKED ABOUT, THEY ARE DEALING
WITH THE INCONSISTENCIES AND THE
PROBLEMS.
THERE IS A POLITICAL ASPECT TO
THIS.
HOW WOULD THAT BE RESOLVED?
IS IT POSSIBLE?
>> I HAVE COME TO THE CONCLUSION
NOW THAT THIS INVESTIGATION INTO
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO END.
EVERY DAY WE ARE FINDING OUT
SOMEONE ELSE INVOLVED IN IT.
AS GREGG SAID, THIS
INVESTIGATION SHOULD BE BEYOND
REPROACH.
THERE ARE SO MANY GREAT MEN AND
WOMEN OUT THERE WHO ARE CAPABLE
OF CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION
WITH INTEGRITY.
THE FBI STANDS FOR INTEGRITY,
THAT IS THEIR MOTTO.
REGARDLESS OF WHO IT IS, IT
SHOULD NOT BE ABOUT POLITICS.
AND CLEARLY, THEY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED, THESE PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE LAID OUT HAVE
DEMONSTRATED SUCH AN EXTREME
TO JAMES COMEY ABOUT CHANGING
THE LANGUAGE SO THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD NOT BE
CRIMINALLY CHARGED.
SHOULD NOT IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> I THINK THAT MOST OF THE FBI
STROKE, PAGE, JAMES COMEY THAT
ARE SUSPECT BY THE MESSAGES THAT
THEY EXCHANGE, THIS NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT AND DEVIN NUNES
SAYS THAT IT IS TIME THAT YOU
INVESTIGATE YOURSELF, I DISAGRE,
THEY CANNOT INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES FAIRLY AND
OBJECTIVELY.
BUT HE HAS REAL, NO REAL
AUTHORITY TO BRING IN A CASE.
>> David: THAT IS THE CASE
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, THIS
RESISTANCE, PAM, GOES A LITTLE
BIT DEEPER AND A LITTLE BIT
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
COMBINED, AND GREG'S POINTS
ABOUT THEM INVESTIGATING
THEMSELVES, DOES THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL GET US WHERE WE NEED TO
BE IN YOUR OPINION?
>> IS A STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL
KNOWING JEFF SESSIONS, THE
ALREADY DONE, AND WE DO NOT KNOW
ABOUT IT IS COME IN, THESE
HOPING THAT GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS HAS COME IN AND HAS
SOMEBODY INVESTIGATING ALL OF
THEM.
WE HEAR NOW THAT HIS RESIGNING,
McCAIN IS GOING TO RESIGN.
HE SHOULD BE FIRED IF THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE TRUE!
OR HE IS NOT GETTING THE
INVESTIGATING ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE THROUGH A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, BECAUSE GREGG IS RIGHT,
THEY CANNOT INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES.
>> WHAT THIS IS ME OFF ABOUT
MUELLER AND THOSE LACK OF
FAIRNESS AND IMPARTIALITY, HE
KNEW EARLY THIS LAST SUMMER THAT
HE KNEW THAT, REMOVED HIM, BUT
NEVER DISCLOSED IT TO CONGRESS
UPON THEIR DEMANDS.
HE STALLED FOR FOUR LONG MONTHS,
IF YOU TRULY CARE ABOUT THE FAIR
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE, YOU
DO NOT COVER THAT UP.
AND TO THOSE THAT ARGUE, WELL,
HE REMOVED THEM, SO IT IS OKAY,
HOW MUCH DAMAGE TO PEOPLE LIKE
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE DO IN THE
FULL YEAR THAT THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING TRUMP WITH THE FBI
ON THIS ONE, THAT IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ROD
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BEING
OUTSPOKEN, WHAT YOU SAY?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP KNOWS THAT HE
DID NOT DO ANYTHING WRONG, AND
TO THIS IT HAS GONE ON LONG
ENOUGH.
AND THAT IS WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID WHAT HE SAID.
HE KNOWS THAT HE DID NOT DO
ANYTHING WRONG, HE KNOWS, THIS
BEEN.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS THE LOWEST IT
HAS DONE NOTHING WRONG, WE NEED
TO MOVE ON.
>> David: GREGG, YOU KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG AND
YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT, HAS HE
SET HIMSELF UP CORRECTLY WITH
>> FIRST OF ALL, HE SAID EXACTLY
CRITICIZE MUELLER HIMSELF, HE IS
SMART ENOUGH TO DO THAT WITHOUT
CONSUL SLIM AND COUNSEL, THAT IS
WHAT HE DID.
IN TERMS OF BROAD ROSENSTEIN.
HE HAS A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
THAT HE CONTINUES TO INSIST THAT
HE WILL NOT RECUSE HIMSELF FROM
THE CASE.
HE CONTINUES TO INSIST THAT ALL
IS WELL.
EVERYTHING IS PERFECT.
MR. ROSENSTEIN, EVERYTHING IS
NOT PERFECT WITH ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN REMOVED BECAUSE
OF MISCONDUCT IN THIS CASE AND A
SUSPICION OF WRONGDOING.